[Music]
anybody hear about astro world yeah no
that's the travis scott concert a bunch
of people got trampled or something
right bunch of people died like eight
people
100 people got injured oh my god so
travis scott uh
who is a rapper for contact i'm aware
because of the mcdonald's thing oh yeah
the christmas oh the top burger there it
is there it is the quarter pounder
with i forgot the barbecue sauce my
bacon it's pretty it's very good it's
actually pretty good oh you got it yeah
i'm a fan of that meal ooh i haven't had
mcdonald's in a minute you should order
for lunch how many people how many
people passed away so eight people so
far uh yeah eight people eight people
died one even one lady was left with
brain damage um
concert stampede man what happened so
they called they're calling it a crowd
surge
right so once this concert started there
was a huge surge and literally um so he
was doing what do they consider a surge
i guess like it's like when uh let's say
you're at a music festival right and
then uh your [ __ ] favorite artist
finally gets to the main stage so
everyone bum rushes to the front right
but this is already like a damn near max
capacity uh actual world tour for him
there's over capacity um there's like
you know over 50 000 people there in
houston and then the search just begins
happening and literally um like as i'm
reading different articles of like
different people's accounts whether it
be like their own friends family members
people that survive people that didn't
it's there was just a moment where the
pressure of people
crushing forward made it so that one you
first recognized that you if you had a
limb up you couldn't bring it down oh
you're just smashed yeah like everything
got super smash
and then there's even like i i remember
it's honestly a little bit depressing
but i was reading this uh first person
account
talking about there's that moment when
you realize it gets too serious and then
you look at people next to you and you
see the the fear of death in their eyes
everyone's like i can't everybody
recognizes that it gets that point and
then you and then because of uh
there's kind of no upward pressure with
it because of gravity and stuff but
there's pressure and something needs to
go somewhere people end up starting to
like it it almost was being explained
like sinkholes like people would just
start falling under
and then after that you would just see
people getting trampled why is it like
people were pushing to the front so
people in the back were creating the
pressure yeah so people in the back who
like obviously especially at like eye
level height you don't know the
the type of pressure you're putting on
and no one wants to back up yeah and and
the backup pressure is not the same
either because even in a large concert
or music people are screaming for help
like no no like you're just hearing
scream you're hearing music it's just
chaos yeah it's just utter chaos don't
they have security guards in the front
that's kind of like
they pull people out well so this this
is this is all part of like a lot of uh
i wouldn't controversy is too strong a
word but like a lot of just the hot
topic of the conversation um there's
lawsuits going on there's a bunch of
like non-contextual videos showing of
people saying like uh travis was aware
of things that happening of these things
happening but like not choosing to stop
the concert whereas there's other videos
that are surfacing showing that like at
his astro world tours like when
something does happen he will stop
seeing and be like security helps person
so everybody's trying to point the
finger because something really tragic
happened but nobody knows how to like
handle such a bro he doesn't know what
the [ __ ] is going on he's on stage
remembering his lyrics
but the thing about it is like he has a
history he like he's been sued before
for inciting like riots at his [ __ ]
concerts and all this [ __ ] so there's a
history of somebody like tried to like
steal his shoes before on stage so he
like was encouraging like the mob to
like beat this dude up one time
so it's a mixed bag right because it
seemed like the the security wasn't
ready there was a there's a bunch of
videos of
before the concert people like hundreds
of people maybe not hundreds but like it
was a good amount of [ __ ] people
rushing through the barricades and
knocking over the security and running
through and he was saying like yeah like
it's over i guess there was a tweet that
he put out saying like all the wild ones
like come to the [ __ ] show even if
it's sold out and it was over capacity
so there was a bunch of history with
that and then i saw i was reading
something this morning about how
the uh i think it was in houston right
the
like police chief of houston actually
met with travis scott
and was like regarding all the issues
that he's had in his past as far as the
history of him kind of stirring up the
crowd and the lawsuits and all this [ __ ]
and he was pretty much having a
conversation with them nobody knows what
was actually being said but i think it
was along the lines of hey like just be
ready because there's some
like reports of this being overcrowded
already and we don't want to stir up
more [ __ ] so it's he had a conversation
with the police officer before and i
guess still nothing really like
came out of that and then for people to
be dead hundreds of people injured it's
crazy is the lesson here don't go to hot
artists like concert anymore like
my friend went to a dmx concert when he
was live and he was like saying that it
was very open yeah dude go to the dolly
parton i go to dolly parton live
no no problem i think it definitely
depends on the style of music or the you
know the also the type of crowd right
because like if you're gonna go to
a very very hype whether it be like rock
or rap or anything where the energy is
meant to be like mob style thrashy
almost belligerent a little bit
absolutely you're gonna do the old
artists that were like high energy randy
travis
yes they're in their 30s and above and
then you got all these og's there
no one's mosh pitting dude no yeah
that's true
limp biscuit high energy but everyone's
just sitting down yep you know
smash mountain smash yeah
smash mouth is gonna go riot bro be
crazy but yeah but everyone's sitting
down that already makes you feel crazy
i just want to rip off that's his next
uh that's the next tour it's like travis
scott x dashboard confessional just make
sure it's like
balanced either delilah hansen
counselor you guys been to dude how many
40 year old tits do the backstreet boys
see every night every night my buddy
filmed a kiss cruise that's so often and
he was showing he was telling me my
buddy uh he filmed a kiss crew and he
was saying dude he saw so many old
titties this is people yeah
i'm going nuts i would not complain if i
only got old titties if anyone's willing
to flash titties to me i'll be like hey
dude that's true yeah that's a special
moment yeah yeah yeah back when uh when
we were touring with el mefeo and they
would perform sexy i know it we would
see like so many titties and then for
some weird reason we went to australia
and it was only dicks guys would show
you dicks there were dudes standing on
shoulders it was only they would just
pull their pants sea of dicks
guys are sitting on other guys shoulders
and they're taking the dick out their
dicks [ __ ] hitting their guys i don't
know if it's that long
but oh they're like cheerleaders like
step like standing on it because i was
like yeah if you're on someone's
shoulder your dick is on their neck
australia's my vibe dude i don't like
their culture are you [ __ ] with me
man no they're taking their [ __ ] out
was there not alone where else just
stopped saying and it's just like whoa
put those away
hey what the [ __ ]
you're in europe america everywhere
girls are like always titties always
titties and then just the five like we
did a tour in australia called stereo
sonic and it was all dicks and like
dudes would like literally run naked and
then get tackled by security
and it was like
and like the whole time we're dancing
you could pay attention to all of that
we're just like why is it all my dad are
the chicks putting more sweatshirts on
it's just [ __ ] down under
logic they're bundling up
down under line it's like the toilet
spin the other way so
it makes sense
yeah right yeah australia's my vibe
right here can't even control it they're
just like this is just how things are
that makes a lot of sense huh yeah i
don't know i think i think it's like a
it's like a joke it's a humor thing i
believe i don't i don't think it's like
it's not a gay thing it's just like
that's funny to them that's why there's
not too many australian comedians you
know it's not very funny they're humans
there's only one dicks are funny though
i thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
that's pretty funny not if you're a sex
icon
they're supposed to be a sex icon always
pulling their dicks out this guy's sex
all the time that's good dude this what
a rock star life man this guy literally
is
[Laughter]
were they trying to get uh red foods
attention i've seen a lot of different
ways to do it but that was the funniest
one for sure i remember i went to like a
bunch of rays in high school and one of
the most packed ones
it probably was like a surge i remember
like azure walking and as the speed
picks up sometimes your feet start
leaving the ground yeah and there's
times where you're just getting carried
and you're like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and you feel like you want to like squat
low to like get yourself grounded again
but you can't you're just being carried
by the mop so i know how scary that
feels that's what some of the reports
were like people were like floating in
the air but at least that was kind of
like stop and go where people were like
as soon as it starts picking up speed
people whoa whoa whoa and then there's
like enough like self-regulation within
the crowd yeah but then for it to just
keep going it's probably pretty freaky
and people are high and drunk they don't
know what the [ __ ] is that's true
they've been mobby experiences
they said before i was writing some
other reports about before the concert
even like before he even came out they
had like a timer
they said like the emts were all backed
up from people getting like od in and oh
and they they already didn't have the
capacity there so it was like on
multiple ends like everybody was getting
[ __ ] thrashed and then people were
yelling like stop the concert before
this [ __ ] guy came out
so like it's crazy i saw a little
five-year-old on someone's shoulders
a five-year-old but they were from the
video that i saw i don't know if it's
from that concert it looked like they
were having fun for a little bit but i
think the rest of it was just completely
[ __ ] but when you do move in a motion
though with the herd it just feels like
this massive human wave this energy goes
yeah only when it works though other
than that you got the marijuana smoke
and you got people puking on the side
and everything else and you kind of just
like
you just kind of tunnel vision and then
you go oh yeah everyone's just singing
the songs and then you leave
i can also imagine how crazy it is
because like
similar things when you go to music
festivals and stuff like that usually
the people who want to get to the front
are the ones who are like most [ __ ] up
because that's the most sensory
experience right so like yeah whether
you're on like e or acid or anything
like that you want to be by the speaker
you want to like see the lights and
stuff like that so
most of the time you already have the
most [ __ ] up people in the front that
like aren't really fully there and like
you always in every one of those
concerts you see security just picking
fainting people out or like overdose
people out that like can't stand anymore
and stuff like that so
that's a normal concert so to to have a
freak accident i can only imagine like
how intense it must have been in that
space did that [ __ ] ever happen during
michael jackson concerts back in the day
they said the deaths of this called to
mind a 1979 concert by the who where 11
people died as thousands of fans tried
to get into cincinnati's riverfront
coliseum and holy [ __ ] and then other
past crowd catastrophes include the
deaths of 97 people in an overcrowded
hillsborough stadium in 97 in sheffield
england so it's all just overcrowding
surges that are like people getting
trampled pretty much dude you hear out
here in the field you're like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's my job yeah we gotta get to
the front
we're too late
[Music]
you